seht ihr das da hinter mir wer errät was
heute passiert wir kommen zu Tag 5 auf
unserem neuen Bauernhof und heute machen
wir eine ganz besondere Ecke auf dem Hof
sauber und ich sag's euch das ist
gefährlich hier wenn man faulenzt
während die anderen putzen dann wird man
auch schon mal gefangen genommen
wahrscheinlich habt ihr es alle schon
lange erraten heute ziehen unsere neuen
Hühner ein und vorher machen wir
natürlich alles ganz schön gemütlich für
die wir hatten die letzten 10 Jahre auch
schon immer Hühner aber ganz kurz vor
unserem Umzug hier auf den Hof wurden
die leider gefressen von dem Jungen
Fuchs der tagsüber auf die Weide
gekommen ist also mussten wir neue
Hühner holen das hier ist Athene das ist
tetes und das plüschige Seidenhuhn heißt
Käfer löscht es hat sich erstmal
versteckt aber es ist natürlich alles
auch ganz neu für die die müssen erstmal
hier ankommen haben das habe ich sie
noch auf die Stange gesetzt weil die die
von selber gar nicht gefunden haben und
am nächsten Morgen sahstättest da oben
am nächsten Tag habe ich dann noch mal
die Klappe aufgemacht und die nach
draußen ins Gehege zu lassen aber keine
Chance die sind noch zu schüchtern